a lot of people got fixated on the
dolphins
and i know i think the odds some eyes i
mean it depends on what you
which are you see i think at the top of
the list of the odds
is staying with the texans which is
logical yeah tactical
dolphins the jets are right there though
right a lot of people fixated on the
dolphins
because that was the report uh that he
would wave there's no trade clause to go
to miami and the dolphins 10-6
defense just need a quarterback miami
you know state tax south beach blah blah
blah man i'm telling you though the jets
and if i may take woody johnson out of
it please and christopher johnson out of
it just for purposes let's just take
talk about from from gm down joe douglas
robert sala a coach he wanted the texans
to interview
and would people underestimate and i and
i think
i think we have a graphic of the draft
capital that joe douglas
has accumulated when people
underestimate
when they say and i've heard people i've
seen this written and heard it said
that uh the jets would have to sacrifice
so much
to get him that they would otherwise
use to build their team
yo they have so many picks
that look at that they don't they can't
give up too much
at the expense of building their roster
so they have two first this year
a second this year which is again at the
top of the second round so it's damn
near first look at that six figures in
the top 100
right is that six in the top four yes
six in the top 98
exactly that's amazing fourth two fifths
a six and a seven and then in 2022 they
have two first
three six and they're missing the fourth
but bottom line is
they could outbid anybody still have
enough picks
to make a dent in this draft class
and again desean watson is a pie piper
michael
he the knicks no coincidence not just
because in
new york but you have a lot of people
who you know this is their allegiance is
you know mets nixon jets the knicks
and the jets are the same thing insofar
as like
the knicks just need a guy to go there
and other people will follow
if deshawn ended up in new york which by
the way he really loves new york city
much as the south beach is appealing he
loves new york city if deshaun watson
goes to new york city
guaranteed people are signing up to play
with him
like they're a contender overnight
there's buffalo miami new york in that
division the patriots will be looking up
at all three teams
in that instance oh i agree number one
i want everybody and and i i couldn't
get a commitment from you on this i want
a firm commitment
i want you and everybody else i said it
before
to apologize to the new york jets if
they get deshawn watson
just humble yourselves and apologize for
just going in on the jets and how stupid
they are for winning games and they
missed out on trevor lawrence and they
got somebody better
than deshawn watson that's number one
but number two uh you're right
if you get you know what a quarterback
you know what michael i'll give you that
now
don't don't keep going but i'll give you
that now i'll probably
call it do you apologize now no i'll
give you the weight until you know that
no
no no but even the possibility of the
thing yeah it's about the possibility of
the thing
i'll give that to them now because your
points they're not they're positioned
you're right they're not that
bad i know they just won a couple
that during of games even before yes i
did i think you said that i think
you bring in because beckton is good
they they hit makai beckton is good uh
denzel mims got a lot of potential
so they've got some you get a
quarterback
in there wow you've changed
like a quarterback in this league uh you
you have some five and six win teams i
know uh houston is a different category
they had a great quarterback and only
won four games
they got somebody he couldn't mask up
all the things that that plagued the
houston texans from the top
all the way down you know they really
are uh uh
tore up from the floor up they are the
taxes
but the jets a great quarterback
like watson can cure a lot of their
perceived problems
and it's as you said it's new york city
i'm sorry yeah it's not the giants it's
the jets
and there are lots of jet jokes that you
can come up with
no joke you get deshawn watson you are a
player in the game
no cap i like it no cat yeah listen
everybody else you can't say that about
everybody else if they if they make a
trade they gotta
they gotta sacrifice a lot of the core
that means attractive to begin with
scott packer green is just jet green hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
three to five pm eastern time on peacock
appreciate you